funny girl ist die geschichte der
komikerin massine
unter dieser burka sehe ich gar nicht so
schlecht aus
sie müssen nicht nur ist heiraten bevor
sie es heraus winken kann
die 20 jährige kurdin wächst in london
auf im spannungsfeld zwischen tradition
und moderne
eigentlich besuch die muslime in einem
comedy kurs setzt alles daran sich von
althergebrachten patriarchalen und
religiösen zwängen zu befreien
der neuseeländer und wahl-londoner
anthony mccarten hat fall geschrieben
ein normaler kurz nach den londoner
terroranschlägen 2005 stieß attentate
verübt im namen des islam
aufgerüttelt wagt sich als ihm erstmals
auf die bühne mit bürgern
sag mal bringt das eine bombe hätte
ein witz der karten bei der standard
kombi den stasi am elsa ausgeliefert
vorbild für die romanfigur als
gelernt
in london gegen hoch
sie war so überrascht
obwohl der klage gegen die frau und fünf
dritte vor ihrer
kaserne war die erste muslimische
komikerin die weltweit bekannt wurde
heute trifft man die londoner in mit
pakistanischen wurzeln ohne kopftuch ein
sie haben sich die haare gewaschen
erklärt sie immer komisch dass sie für
funny girl modell stand ist für sie eine
überraschung
es schmeichelt mir das mein leben
inspiration solange es nicht playboy
penthouse demografische zeitschrift ist
habe ich nicht
murza und dass sie haben einiges
gemeinsam
zwar trägt nur die romanfigur balkan
beide werden aber nach alter väter sitte
erzogen verschweigen ihr treiben
gegenüber den familien und stoßen auf
widerstand
als meine eltern herausfand dass ich
komikerin wollten sie es lange nicht
wahrhaben ich glaube es ist wie wenn man
schwul ist
sie wird bald wieder in ordnung sei
ebenfalls galt ist die vorurteile der
gesellschaft zu überwinden stehvermögen
war die voraussetzung für ihre steile kg
denn viele moslems sahen in der komik
und den auftritten einen unverzeihlichen
patenten
ein verstoß gegen den koran zeit ist
allerdings nicht sagt jasmin elsebad
schweiz ägyptische doppelbürgerin und
autorin selbst die burka sei
unproblematisch im gegenteil
also ich finde das natürlich fantastisch
oder will gerade hat sie mit der burka
auf löhnen gekommen das ist ein bisschen
so umstritten ist das ist der erste
schritt meines erachtens um wirklich
schon mal einfach die ganze religiöse
scheinheiligkeit
pch und vor allem über bitter unser
religiöser mensch fragt einfach mal
abschalten und sagen ich bin frau ich
will frei sie ich mache was ich will
kürzlich war ich bei einer hochzeit der
imam sagte braut und bräutigam könnten
sich auf so vieles freunden zum beispiel
auf die parität
meine eltern wollten unbedingt dass ich
meine aber muslime wollen mich nicht
weil ich rede
rede und entscheidungsfreiheit auch im
kreiert ein thema mit sprengkraft sowohl
außen als auch mercer feiern zu erfolgen
bekommen aber mord
ich glaube eine morddrohung ist aber
weiß dass man es richtig macht
den mut ihre stimme zu erheben haben
übrigens nicht nur migranten auch in
islamischen ländern drängen comedians in
die öffentlichkeit wie nora kette in
ägypten
in unkenntnis dessen glaubt der westen
aber immer noch die islamische welt
seine humorfreie zone
es geht selbstverständlich homo indes
islamisch arabisch holzmann 18
religiöse würdenträger
scheinheiligkeit der umgang mit religion
im alltag was ihn sehr wohl thema neuro
juristisch oft genug als ganzes sehen
natürlich ganz klar der große
figur von prophet muhammad kurz es geht
in der tradition netz wir in europa über
die religiöse führer war eigentlich ein
ergebnis der ruf klar rechtlich
die freiheit über alles zu lachen liegt
in weiter ferne der arabische frühling
sei wieder dem winter gewichten zu
eltern warten zensur auch bei familien
nimmt wieder zu
er lässt die mauern einstürzen die uns
trennen
ich bekomme hassmails
zb du machst dir du bist
analysten betonen